we went on the wire tangent but
we're talking about michael b jordan so
you saw him in the stu in the uh in the
uh he was yoked up
floyd mayweather's first okay so i was
like oh that's wallace and then
a couple i didn't know what he was doing
there he was just watching and you know
one thing about michael b jordan once
he's
you know he gets into character and do
the research and
right she's like so great at that so i
seen him a couple months later
i was like hey bro he was with a
childhood friend of mine who i used to
box with in louisiana
got you he was like hey bro you know hey
talk to michael b jordan he cool and
the guy my guy my friend is his corey
collette he's uh
his body trainer he's you know the one
who's getting him yoke and then uh
i talked to him it was cool he was like
bro i like this you know it's a good
vibe
and then michael b jordan just like i i
brought up i was like
remember i called you wallace and
floyd's he was like yeah bro that was
you yeah
and you know we clicked ever since
that's crazy yeah he seems like a
pretty pretty cool dude man i told him i
wanted to act this is how cool he is
right so i'm on a set
of uh creed i was like bro i really want
to do this acting stuff right okay cool
but i think you should be boxing i was
like you don't know my life
right so uh he goes all right you wanna
act so he
he had his agent like send me an
audition for barbershop three
oh wow bro you know hey i have an agent
he like kind of worked as my agent
he was like hey get my audition give him
a look and i was like okay cool thank
you bro and for sure
i thought it was coming from michael b
jordan i was like i got the part
didn't get it